this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
we start here at six o'clock with some
breaking news a murder investigation
happening right now in the east valley
one person has been shot and killed and
right now police are looking for that
suspect hector mejia live near nellis
and boulder highway with the latest
information from metro hector good
morning
good morning we just learned the victim
was in his 30s the shooter still on the
run and we just got an update from metro
police they tell us it all happened
right at the bus stop right there at
nellis and boulder highway
and right after the shooting up people
tried to help the victim but he died at
the hospital and just a short time ago
we got an update from lieutenant jason
johansen he told us what they believe
happened right after this incident
the shooting occurred
the victim fled
northbound from the area to receive help
and the suspect fled the opposite
direction
so police tell us the victim ran over
near sam's town asked for help collapsed
they rushed him to the hospital but
again did not survive and we still have
this active scene here now this is the
second murder investigation from
overnight from metro police but they
tell us they do not believe these two
scenes are related reporting live hector
mejia live local now